the new program putting teenagers in the
shoes of military cadets for the goal it
uses exercise and character development
to teach them how to be more accountable
for themselves mary jane billy is
joining us live in the newsroom to
explain good morning mary jane good
morning heather one local mom says this
program is not only about giving your
kids a second chance but parents a
second chance too the battleborn youth
challenge academy is spearheaded by the
nevada national guard with the goal of
improving life skills and employment
potential for teens who have fallen
behind on school credits it's a
six-month program that is tuition-free
and teens live on campus and use a
quasi-military structure style to teach
the teens accountability discipline and
so much more parent nicole zamora says
while the program takes place up in
northern nevada she wants to raise
awareness of how beneficial this program
is and says her daughter esmeralda even
graduated at the top of her class last
month
it is a voluntary program so the
children have to be willing to go and i
talked to her about it i explained to
her what i was mentioning earlier like i
think you deserve the opportunity to be
the best you that you can be
and this will give you a chance to just
get away from all the distractions not
even worrying about me and what i have
going on in my work schedule and your
sister and sports and
just life in general
now zamora says while the camp isn't
easy her daughter came back focused and
motivated and not only helped her
daughter physically but mentally and
even academically as well zamora says
you can reach out to her on the email
provided below if you'd like to learn
more about her and her daughter's
experience with the battleborn youth
camp reporting live in the newsroom mary
jane boyzen live local now